tell us your sleep pattern you said you
became an author and I think the
audience wants to know what is the so
one of the I had several reasons to
become an author none of which are
particularly because I like writing
books or I was particularly good at it
but I wanted I had a list of things I
wanted to uh visualize and accomplish in
my life never have to talk to someone I
don't want to
um work for myself have a legacy and
also sleep in when I go my natural sleep
pattern so I go to bed at 2 A.M I wake
up at 11 and this I've been doing this
for years so whenever that's kind of
messed up I am just uh low-key Michael
you literally go to sleep at 2 am and
you wake up at 11. every day Monday
through Sunday so right so when we said
podcast 9 to 11 you thought it was late
night no no no no no I didn't think that
at all you said come to the show and I
said sure then you're like oh it's 11.
so you did a bait and switch on me yeah
you never have a morning meeting in your
life Michael sends me a message I used
to do Glenn Beck's show uh in the
morning um and that was hell on Earth
I'll say one thing uh back to your
schedule is is the exact opposite of
what I was looking for in my life
because I used to work in nightlife in
Miami right and I was sick of waking up
at noon every single day I would go to
bed at four or five in the morning a
little later than you right and wake up
at noon and I was like I gotta get my
life together but that this is my
biorhythm Hey listen what's the point of
being successful if you can't set your
own terms Michael if those are your
buyers what audience wants to know is
what are your pronouns that's that's it
that's awesome sir okay so I got you and
if you can somehow convince Pat to get
on your schedule you were a great
salesman she should be on his schedule
yeah it might not work for him you
should take advantage of the whole
pronoun thing just make your pronouns
tired and shut up I'm not tired I'm just
kind of that's this pattern Tom yeah
what's wrong with that you know you know
what's crazy so so yesterday while we're
talking about this yesterday I do my the
the executive physical that I do every
every couple years you're going at 6 30
in the morning kind of time time you
wake up and and they literally take you
from Doctor to doctor to doctor and they
test everything right they check your
heart your skin your breathing your you
know everything they do it's phenomenal
you see nine or ten doctors in a span of
nine hours okay and
the lady asked me a question she said so
how much sleep do you get per night
and uh I felt compelled to sell her my
sleep pattern I said listen I just want
to let you know there you know that aura
ring thing that you people wear so yeah
so I wore it for like six months and
it's not
how much sleep you get is how much deep
sleep you get because according to or I
get a lot of deep sleep and she says
really I said yes she says you still
need to figure out a way to sleep seven
hours a night because I'm doing four to
six whatever the time is for me and I
said look it works for some it doesn't
work for some but it is what it is I
think that's what it is some people are
you know the whole morning person night
person I think there is some truth
behind that certain people are nice
you're awake in the morning you're not a
person there's something wrong with you
but early bird is not getting the worm
in your house they're getting a shotgun
but roosters
but the thing is I think extremely
extremely successful people often are
the ones whose uh evolutionary
advantages I get buying for as I sleep
like Clinton had four hours of sleep
Thatcher famously had four hours of
sleep and they could just get by you're
getting nine hours I'm getting ice I'm a
failure yeah I'm like I'm 12 to 15 we
hear it's sleep well if there's anything
you're not as a failure people love
listening to you your opinions well
maybe people thinking but maybe they're
failures yeah that's that's a that's a
person perspective to him right you're
failing I'm winning I'm Michael malis
right I'm the white pill guy so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign
[Music]